civil rights from the zoot suit riots to
the women's movement
conspiracy theories are not new to the
u.s however they have changed over time
indiana university bloomington professor
steven andrews teaches a class about
conspiracy culture in american history
and points out they often include groups
such as the illuminati freemasons and
skull and bones
this is the first of a two-part seminar
where he talks about how in the 1950s a
prominent aspect of conspiracy theories
was the threat of communism but in later
decades a global new world order became
more common this seminar hosted by the
gilder layerman institute of american
history is about an hour and 20 minutes
thank you guys so much i have been this
is my second year i also did some other
things with the museum i like to thank
everybody at the 911 museum they're
fantastic as you all know
so easy to work with gilda lairman is
fantastic the entire staff is wonderful
it had it hit me last year and i thought
that maybe this year it would be
different that i hadn't had already
experienced the 911 museum and now it
would become old hat being in this space
and it's not right this space as you
know as well as anybody over the last
five days is is hallowed ground and it
is a powerful
place and a hard place in a sense to do
something as mundane as give a lecture
so i'm going to do my best to do that
and i say that because some of the
things we're going to talk about are
weird some of them are funny some of
them are scary some of them are gross
and i don't want any of that to seem
disrespectful to the space that we're in
nothing we can do you know as lincoln
said can unhallow this ground that is
hallowed but i do want you to know that
i'm
cognizant as i'm sure you are of the
space that we're in but still have to do
the task we have before us
my name is steve andrews as ed said i
had a great pleasure of working with ed
and continue to work with him
i'm from a small southern town
in florida
brandon outside of tampa i was raised as
a fundamentalist evangelical southern
baptist i say that because we will talk
at some points conspiracy culture
interacts with american religion
and we have to talk about that and when
we do i don't want it to ever seem that
i'm being
derisive or
joking about religious things i think
that's crucially important both to me
personally and professionally as a
historian but we need to talk about some
of those issues but i'm just laying that
out that the place that i'm coming from
is not a place from outside religion but
within it and so any criticisms that i'm
making or comments that i'm making are
from a person who is part of a culture
that you're also critiquing
when i was in when i was in graduate
school
i was working on
spiritualism i'm not sure how familiar
you are of spiritualism but spiritualism
was the popular belief in the 1850s that
it was possible to talk to the spirits
of the dead and it becomes a kind of
cultural
phenomenon of people having seances and
it goes through the 1860s of talking to
the dead and the fox sisters in 1848 and
the thing that fascinated me was i was
well familiar with the academic work on
religion and folk belief things like
keith thomas's uh religion
religion and the decline of magic right
which is that as we become more modern
in the enlightenment our beliefs and
things like witches and
monsters and fairies are diminishing and
yet in the 1850s at a time of steamships
in the telegraph when we're laying
trans-atlantic telegraph cables that
link new york and london people in
america and in other parts of europe but
particularly in america are being
fascinated in deeply believing in the
existence of talking to spirits how do
you have both things how do we move in
this direction towards modernity
establishing
the erie canal and the steamship and the
telegraph and at the same time this
culture is also looking back to beliefs
that would not be out of place in salem
in the 1690s right
so but i want to talk also so keep that
in the back of your head i want to talk
about when i say conspiracy theorists or
we talk about american conspiracies what
are some of the kind of conspiracies
that we're talking about what are
conspiracies that you know of in the
united states yes ma'am
we did not land on the moon the moon
hoax yes i had a student tell me this
year that the las vegas shooting was
employed by the united states government
to take away american stuff right this
is second amendment kind of new world
order stuff yes
sandy hook didn't happen
right others
jfk assassination
holocaust didn't happen
parkland shooting is set up right so
kids crisis actors so we could go on and
on and on right so here's a short list
kennedy assassination birthers obama
wasn't born in the united states
truthers 911 was an inside job ufos that
the united states government is hiding
information about aliens and ufos right
uh fema new world order jade helm
martial law this is the we're going to
put people in fema camps the atf is
going to take our guns we can disarm the
american population this is crisis
actors around every shooting right nafta
and the amero is it people with romero
the amero was nafta is the north
american free trade agreement there was
an argument in the 1990s that nafta was
leading into what was going to be a
tri-union of united states mexico and
canada that would use a new dollar bill
called the amero in fact there were
reports coming out about red money
and so when we've redesigned our
currency you have recognized redesigned
our currency when people saw stacks of
those the thought was this is going to
be the amero this will be our new dollar
right vaccines gm foods mercury autism
weather modifications chemtrails the fed
the moon landing was hoax
u.n conspiracies agenda 21 agenda 21 was
signed in rio de janeiro it is the u.n
agenda for sustainable growth
environmental protection and other
things
supposedly in the eyes of many
conspiracy theorists this is the bill uh
this is the plan of radical population
reduction
to get the population of the united of
the world down to 300 million
using chemtrail all these things often
tie together right um crisis actor
standard her bilderberger's bilderberg
conference is a conference of world
economic and political leaders that is
closed to the public ross childs
widespread population reduction right
yes sorry will you be able to share this
powerpoint with us absolutely
yes so uh yeah so many so i think there
are
and this as we talked about it if you
wanted to we could have gone on for
another 20 minutes coming up with deeper
and deeper conspiracies right or
different versions of the same ones
so a wide range some of them are
spectacular and truly weird david ike
who i'm not sure if you're familiar with
david ike is a british broadcaster
sports broadcaster who became convinced
that the royal family and other world
leaders are all actually shape-shifting
aliens who are lizards
and that that the the the royal families
of europe that are all tied by blood
right in world war one all of the
combatants in europe are all kin they're
all cousins right so they're all a
family in a sense that they are all
actually shape-shifting lizards um not
believed by very many but spectacular
there are some that are believed in
nearly evergreen right the kennedy
assassination there are kennedy
assassination
conspiracy believers of all stripes from
all different places and we'll talk
about that a little bit um others are
widespread but keyed into cultural
moments like the birther controversy the
birth of controversy was very big news
in the late 20 teens will probably not
be huge news 15 20 years from now it's
not probably going to be the kennedy
assassination there are some that never
take right there was an argument that
obama sabotaged the deep water horizon
in the gulf of mexico
for
to have new policies against oil use to
push solar power i you know but this one
came up
was sampled everyone was like no and
then it kind of went away again right so
this happens in this kind of life cycle
of conspiracy theories um
so but the reality and one of the things
we have to think about and the second
part we'll be talking about what we do
with our students and how we talk to our
students about conspiracies and how we
talk to our fellow american citizens
about conspiracies one of the things we
have to acknowledge as part of this
conversation is that conspiracies exist
um
if you say that conspiracy is a group of
people working together often in secret
to advance an agenda beneficial to them
then conspiracies are literally
everywhere every corporation that is
coming up with a new rollout of the
bacon double cheeseburger with rio sauce
the 11's herbs and spices in kfc the
secret uh you know the secret formula of
coke what i mean is people meet in
secret to do all kinds of things for
their own interests and right now maybe
less now than in the cold war there are
people in high-rise office buildings
thinking of how to protect you the cia
the fbi justice department they were
also certainly when i was a child in the
1980s
living outside of mcdill air force base
there was someone probably not much
older than me
in somewhere in russia sitting on an
icbm targeted with my neighborhood right
there are secret groups working against
you and protecting you we live in a web
of secrecy not all of it is a conspiracy
but we have to recognize that
conspiracies do exist right
so
i think
that when we talk about conspiracy
culture we talk about conspiracies it
seems like we're talking about something
that's weird and strange and outside of
the mainstream outside of the way that
most of us
let's because we all generally think of
us as a group
right educated educators who teach
people we are not part of this group
that group is out there and this is a
fringe strange
part of american culture i disagree
i think that conspiracies is how
americans do politics it is often the
first move when i heard yesterday maybe
you did too that stormy daniels got
arrested i had conversations with no
less than five people about it yesterday
who are all of differing education
levels from high school to postgraduate
medical school who all said
they set her up who they is why they set
her up but the first thought is they set
her up right
right
there's a growing sense in the united
states so i'm going to trace some of
these conspiracies from early on in our
founding to the present day of about
this is a way that americans do politics
think politically
and it is also part of our and maybe
other countries too i don't know that
it's just unique to america but america
is what i've studied and it certainly is
a powerful force here the way we think
about politics whether it is
bernie was rooked out of by a conspiracy
of the clintons or trump saying this is
a conspiracy
to get me unelected or all of these
simple things probably down to every
local school board of a conspiracy to do
one thing or another put in a street
light change the hours of the bus drop
schedule whatever right
so in my own classes i talk about the
occult right and on one level the occult
is exactly what we tend to think of as
the occult werewolves siemens which is
monster's magic right that is the occult
um and that's part of american culture
right i mean certainly salem witch
trials and other places where this kind
of what we tend to think of as
scary supernatural beliefs come up but i
also think there's a big part of the
occult
and the latin sense of a cultist of
hidden
of an american fascination with hidden
knowledge
that shows up in our popular culture
that shows up in our advertisements that
shows up tv shows this idea that
we are americans are haunted by
that the world is not what we see and
the real things that happen and really
affect us the important things are the
things that are happening hidden
underground hidden underground both
metaphorically and quite literally okay
that they
them are making the decisions
and they them are somewhere hidden
underground and we have to find a way to
discover what that reality what reality
actually looks like right so um occult
thinking thinking conspiratorially is
how americans react to the world how
they interact with the world is part of
our popular culture you can also look at
for example if you look at just
advertisements here are 10 ancient diet
secrets that they don't want you to know
that
if you watch
certainly i watched a lot of because
i didn't have a lot better things to do
i watched a lot of oprah and daytime
television during the 80s and 90s right
see here are diet secrets here are
beauty secrets here are things that your
cardiologist doesn't want you to know
here's the way to eat and if you eat
this way you'll magically lose weight
and your cardiologist doesn't want you
to know that so that you stay fat and
have to come and get a heart transplant
whatever right but that idea of there's
a secret knowledge of a way to do things
and some powerful force wants to keep
you from doing that and that is in
politics that is in culture that's in
popular culture right
i looked through the tv listings it is
hard to find a night in tv i would argue
that you might not be able to
to find a night in popular culture where
one of the major shows on networks is
not about exactly this right
is not about
secret groups of agents stopping
underground groups 24 agents of shield
right angels and demons x-files comes
back x-files was massive in the 90s
right but again all of these things
buffy the idea i mean again i was joking
that i was watching um downton abbey
with my wife and i realized about four
episodes in that something was missing
and i turned her and i said where are
the vampires like how how how is it that
we're gonna go four episodes of a show
then like
no one has superpowers like no there's
no under like the kaiser's not a
werewolf how is this possibly a show
right so this is what we are obsessed by
right and it is percolating through our
culture
in ways that
americans are prepared to think that
there is an occult underground world and
a cult not necessarily werewolves and
vampires but hidden that's away from us
that some other people control this was
came up a year ago i showed it and it
was i always try to find things that are
more popular this was so good i couldn't
not use it right this was on twitter
sometimes it's a horrible mistake to let
10 year olds name their own baseball
team then again sometimes they crush it
and the kid has his baseball team
literally team is the illuminati
with the baseball back of the jersey
being trust no one with the all-seeing
illuminati eye
i think if you would have let me name my
bar
when i was on kin's barbershop which is
my actual little league team when i was
10
we would have never come up with
illuminati right
so what does it mean to have
kids name themselves after
as we'll talk about a 1770s
enlightenment underground movement in
bohemia
and to have trust no one
as the tagline now partially this is
from the x-files this is a joke this is
not serious or is it right what does
this say about our culture um
joseph vicinski studies conspiracy
theories did a study for his 2014 book
and asked big events like wars the
current recession and the outcomes of
elections are controlled by small groups
of people who are working in secret
against the rest of us we'll talk about
more on this in our second hour
right only 30 disagree
okay
kyrie irving believes the earth is flat
they lie to us right so part of this is
i don't want to necessarily make fun of
kyrie irving but i wanted to read some
of this right so this is from the
sporting news not known as necessarily
being deep into conspiracy theories but
this is the idea that the earth is truly
flat and this is being hidden
okay
so the earth is flat irving said matter
of factly irving joins rapper bob as a
notable denier of a sphere-shaped planet
anytime you have a specific question
like quote is the earth flat or is the
earth round i think you need to do
research on it i think we would all
agree when asked how he can believe the
flat theory irving responded because it
is right in front of our faces they lie
to us irving also acknowledged that he
has been taught his entire life that the
planet is round but thinks logically it
just doesn't make sense and now the
words of kyrie irving if you really
think about it from a landscape the way
we travel the way we move and the fact
that you can can you really think of us
rotating around the sun and all planets
aligned rotating in specific dates being
perpendicular with what's on with these
planets and stuff like this irving
explained using air quotes when saying
the word planets
maybe the cavaliers don't need to
acquire carmelo anthony at the trade
deadline maybe they need
neil degrasse tyson
i am not here necessarily to talk to
make fun of kyra irving who literally
states newton's theory of planetary
motion as a kind of big scam
but
this quote
because it is right in front of our
faces
they
lie to us
trust no one
okay
so stefan diggs from the wide receiver
of the vikings said how mad would you
guys be if i said i agree with kyrie
well i don't care
said someone responded you think the
earth is flat and he said prove that
it's not right now besides showing me a
picture that you got from somewhere and
i'll be a believer
now one this is
we want to not say that here is we're
talking with a wide receiver of
the minnesota vikings about whether or
not the earth is flat but
look at the evidentiary argumentative
moods right which is i don't believe it
they lie to us show me a picture but not
one you got from somewhere
because underneath that is a sense they
lie to us the evidence itself by which
we would argue about whether this is
true or not is so tainted that it is not
accessible and in our in that a circular
argument in which the evidence you want
to introduce will be immediately
discounted because the source you're
going to produce it from are the only
people who could take pictures from
space who are them
we're in a box an intellectual box okay
um
richard hofstetter wrote in 1964 for
harper so it's an article that you could
give to students and i've given to
students it's very accessible easy to
read about the paranoid style and i want
to read a little bit american politics
has often been an arena for angry minds
but behind this i believe there's a
style of mind that is far from new and
that is not necessarily right wing i
call it the paranoid style simply
because no other word adequately evokes
the sense of heated exaggeration
suspiciousness and conspiratorial
fantasy that i have in mind in this
essay from 1964
in the wake of barry goldwater and the
idea of john birch society he's writing
about this but he's also going back in
history and writes about conspiracy in
the 1850s this is from a texas newspaper
in the 1850s it is a notorious fact that
the monarchs of europe and the pope of
rome are at this very moment plotting
our destruction and threatening the
extinction of our political civil and
religious institutions we have the best
reasons for believing that corruption
has found its way into our executive
chamber and that our executive head is
tainted with the infectious venom of
catholicism
so in the 1850s there is a worldwide
conspiracy against the united states but
it's from the pope and it has already
infected the presidency
there are many things you can probably
say about franklin pierce
but i don't think that he was a pawn of
the pope
right
also communist this is joe mccarthy
right speaking in the 1950s which is how
can we account for our present situation
unless we believe that men high in this
government are concerning to deliver us
to disaster
this must be a product of a great
conspiracy on a scale so immense as to
dwarf any previous such venture in the
history of man so not just a conspiracy
the biggest in the history of man and
that this is eisenhower
who won world war ii
is actually a secret pawn of the
communists if not eisenhower then
certainly people high up in the white
house and the truman administration
the paranoid spokesman sees the fate of
conspiracy in apocalyptic terms he
trafficks in the birth and death of
whole worlds whole political orders
whole systems of human values he is
always manning the barricades of
civilization he constantly lives at a
turning point like religious
millennialists he expresses the anxiety
of those who are living through the last
days and he is sometimes disposed to set
a date for the apocalypse
so i want he is writing about political
thinkers but as a religious historian in
particular this language really speaks
out to me in the language of
millennialism and apocalyptic visions
and also when you hear people talk in
american politics they talk about a war
of civilization everything will be over
if we don't have this a border wall or
something else everything will be gone
will be overridden that this kind of
language of this is the election that if
this election doesn't happen it's all
over because of some
dark conspiracy okay
the illuminati
we go back into our history the
illumined ones established in engle stop
bavaria in 1776 founded by adam
weishaupt probably not a real name as it
translates to adam wise head a
university professor is organized to
advance the goals of the enlightenment
so the the illuminati is a real thing
it was a real organization set up for
enlightenment goals that in 1785 carl
theodore
the leader of bavaria um issued a edict
making edict making all secret societies
illegal illuminati fled the country
government seized their letters and
papers and published them basically
showing that they were anti-religious
they the enlightenment was often opposed
to particularly the catholic church and
said this was a reason to expose them
but they show up again in the 1790s in
america and an america that's involved
in uh both a c about to be involved in a
quasi war with france that's between
france and england as they are fighting
a revolution uh francis fighting a
revolution in england is about to fight
a war against france and america's
caught in the middle and if you know
about the election of 1800 from hamilton
et cetera right jefferson was framed as
a french revolutionary who will make the
streets of america run with blood and
adams is phrased as a monarchist who
will return the united states to england
right
and the illuminati was seen as a secret
force
causing the french revolution a small
group of people in bavaria who have
already been dispersed are often accused
in the 1790s of being the secret force
behind the french revolution okay
freemasonry this is a a constant in
american conspiracy theory it comes up
again and again it established in the
18th century
but it claims an ancient connection to
the temple of solomon
it's an international society of
brotherhood with secret signs and
symbols of initiation do you recognize
any of these symbols
right the all-seeing eye of freemasonry
that find its way both onto the american
dollar and onto the jersey of a
ten-year-old little league player
right uh many of these symbols the
parquet floor the all-seeing eye the
apron this is a part of when you look at
the language of symbols of american
conspiracy theories these symbols come
up again and again right and freemasons
are one of those groups they are
pan-national they are pan-cultural in
which they stretch around the world
secret that have secret rituals and
those rituals may be no more complicated
than the lions club in some people's
estimation or part of a secret radical
satanist agenda depending on how you
want to turn it in a sense it's a secret
society we don't know
right
this is a list of famous masonic leaders
it could go on and on 27 signers of the
of the constitution most of the earliest
presidents washington franklin revere
payne monroe jackson polk garfield
mckinley roosevelt harding roosevelt
johnson ford others
easy to make the argument if you were
willing to
connect particular data points that
the united states government itself is a
masonic plot
right the reason the great seal looks
like a masonic symbol is that the masons
are basically behind it all
in new york in 1826 a man named william
morgan tried to join the local mason
lodge and was turned down so he said i'm
going to publish a book revealing all of
your secrets he was arrested
when he was released he never returned
home
a body was found in the river in upstate
new york people thought it was morgan
and there was a full-fledged masonic
panic
that the secret society of the masons
was a murderous conspiracy that was
attempting to take over the united
states and this was not just a fear that
kind of percolated among americans in
upstate new york it became an organizing
principle for a political party and the
anti-masonic party wins elections in
1832 and 1836
it elects anti-masons to political
office and its agenda is against
people in american government being
parts of secret societies because if
you're a part of a secret society you're
not doing the people's work and your
allegiances to something else this was
the argument against kennedy in 1960
the argument that kennedy as a catholic
would have to follow the rules of the
pope rather than be serve the american
people in a sense among people john
birchers and other people uh opposed to
american catholicism generally that you
could not be both a catholic and an
american president because you either
served one master or the other
right
same thing with the anti-masons in the
1830s
but if the modern and i'm not i mean
there are other
conspiracies and other things to go
through i'm going to jump ahead now
because if the way we understand modern
conspiracy theories the way we engage
them with our students with our fellow
american citizens
the way we do it now
changed it's not
this
remember most of these so far are
external things right the pope is
influencing us from the outside right
bankers are influencing us from the
outside masons are from outside the
government creeping in
now
by the modern age we're in now many
times it's the american government
itself so if the modern conspiracy
theories have a birthday it is in 1947
with the national security act of 1947.
it establishes the national security
council it established the cia it
establishes the air force the air force
had prior been part of the army it
established the joint chiefs of staff
and it creates the cia as i said it's
charged with quote other functions and
duties related to intelligence that is
boring government speak for secret
operations right
covert ops the budget of the
intelligence committee was going to be a
national secret it will be a black
budget because if we let the russians
know how much we're paying for things in
the security they'll have an estimate of
how much money we're spending and what
we might be spending it on but this is
really important
because for the first time in american
history
the federal government is saying we are
going to have a part of the government
that is outside of democratic
observation we're going to have a part
of the government that will do secret
things that we won't tell you about that
will spend money that we will not reveal
and we will do it to protect us because
we have to have secrets to protect
ourselves and that secret state has
evolved and grown and grown and involved
in things like the patriot act when it
moves into a whole another level after 9
11 right
but it has a birthday 1947. now the idea
of a secret
part of the government
that does covert operations in a world
of the cold war post world war ii that
we find ourselves in makes a lot of
sense right there is a reason to have
secrets there is a reason that you might
need covert actions so it's not
that this is somehow wicked on its face
but in a population
that trusted the american government
implicitly this is going to be fine
if the people know they trust the
government to make the right decisions
with the power they give them and they
will not abuse it then having a secret
government apparatus isn't a problem but
that is not the country that we are and
it's certainly not the country we are
as we move forward right this creates a
fertile ground for conspiracies there
literally is a box where you can say
the federal government did this and we
know they have secrets and they do
things the defenses against that are one
humans would never do that against each
other that is not a strong argument
given what we know about what humans
would do
it's a stronger argument in the 1940s
and 50s to say the american government
wouldn't do that
so when you get a conspiracy that says
the american government did one thing or
another you say the federal the american
government wouldn't do that
again not a big deal in a society where
the people reflexively trust the
government but it is a big deal
particularly for a group of people who
are politically awakened
by this event
kennedy's shot not to shock you kennedy
was shot in dallas in november 22nd 1963
right
afterward lee harvey oswald is arrested
president is murdered in the middle of
the cold war lee harvey oswald is
arrested we got the guy and then jack
ruby jumps out of a crowd in front of a
row of cameras and police officers
a minor league gangster in dallas jumps
out and shoots the person who shot the
president in front of national tv
in the context of the cold war in the
context of knowing that there is a
national security state in the context
of this stuff moving or just about
really to be moving cultural anxieties
in the 1960s so what do they do
they put earl warren the former governor
of california and the chief justice of
the supreme court in charge of the
warring commission to investigate the
kennedy assassination
this is a bid to say you need to trust
us because if there's one person you can
trust it is the chief justice of the
supreme court the person who in the
country is at the top of our judicial
branch he is going to be in charge of
this commission and says
he acted alone
one man
the warren commission was not believed
when it was issued
in november of 1963 29
believed that one man did it 52
thought others involved and some had no
opinion
as we move into the 1960s and 70s as the
the lack of faith in the united states
government increases as the sense that
the government does bad things goes up
as the fear of the united states
government increases that number goes up
and up and up
in march 20 2001 it's 81 percent
did not believe so what they are saying
is you we had an investigation the
government investigated the chief
justice of the supreme court came out
and said this is what happened and at
some point in 2001
more than three quarters of the american
people go you're lying
trust no one they lie to us
right
and then there are the revelations of
government conspiracies that starts in
the 1970s in the pentagon papers in 1971
leaked documents about what the united
states was doing in vietnam watergate in
1972 that the president himself is about
to be indicted for breaking into the
offices of the dnc at the watergate
hotel operation mongoose there's
investigations the church committee the
committee on assassinations and what
they come out with is these things that
the united states government was doing
operation mongoose we'll talk a little
bit was to harass castro working with
gangsters like sam g and kana co intel
pro was the counterintelligence program
that's monitoring people like martin
luther king that was inserting
government agents into leftist
organizations
like snick or the the uh the you know
the ssds
there were times and jokes that at a
time there would be some civil rights or
leftist meetings in which half the group
was informing on the other half because
half of them were working for the nypd
and the other half were working for the
fbi
right following taking pictures of king
the house select committee on
assassinations comes out in 1976 and
raises doubts itself about the warren
commission
we find out that the cia overthrow
helped or aided the overthrow of iran
and guatemala
tuskegee syphilis experiments in which
african-american men in alabama are
go to a clinic for their syphilis and
are not treated so that government
doctors can monitor how syphilis
progresses through the lifetime because
penicillin has been curing syphilis too
early
without telling them or their partners
right i ran contra in the 1980s that
they're moving guns to nicaragua to to
right-wing groups in nicaragua probably
stargate in 1995. this is the revelation
that through the 1970s and 1980s out of
fort meade maryland
the dia cia that moves around is
operating a program to train psychic
spies to spy and use their powers
against russia
john ronson writes about this in the men
who stare at goats right
project paper clip clinton releases it
all in 1998
some of the documents this is bringing
nazi scientists into the united states
to work here so we fought against the
nazis and it's not this again is not a
revelation as early as 1947 1946 we knew
some of this right um
you know that the the people who
designed the v2 that hit london are very
soon in huntsville alabama working on
the apollo program
right
but this is
project paper clip we release all of the
f
not just the things about the kind of
big figures that everyone knew about but
all of the rest of the nazi
and many of them parts of the nazi party
who were snuck snuck out and into the
united states right so
that argument of well the united states
government wouldn't do this is beginning
to fall apart now too
right so project northwoods was a
proposed secret plan signed by the joint
chiefs though canceled by kennedy to do
a series of false attacks in the u.s
that would be blamed on cuba to justify
military action it's made public in
1997.
so in 1997 when kennedy comes in the
joint chiefs say we want to invade cuba
we need to have a false flag operation
so the conspiracy theorists who are
talking about this are not inventing it
out of whole cloth it's not like they
are they come up with an idea that no
one has ever thought of in the
government right
mongoose was a series of plans to harass
cubans and cuban leader and assassinate
fidel castro
operation dirty trick was a plan that if
john glenn's space capsule blew up they
were going to blame it on cuba so we
have these plants many of them shelves
not used but someone's drafting them
right mk ultra
rockefeller committee first reveals that
the cia was working on mind control
attempting to use lsd to influence
people to be able to question them to
make them more compliant or to turn them
into double agents if they could use
them on russians
the church committee hands over
documents more handed over in 1978 they
randomly drugged civilians there was an
operation called midnight climax in
which
prostitutes the johns coming to visit
prostitutes in california and new york
would be given lsd and then monitored
without their knowledge to see what
would happen to them
so you could live fire test lsd on
subjects to see whether this was the
kind of chemical that would be able to
use to give to for example a spy in
moldova and see what would happen can we
moderate can we weaponize it right
and all of this is coming out in the 70s
in the 80s and later in the 90s it all
seemed so bizarre so sci-fi that it
undercuts something we would desperately
love to be able to say we would love to
be able to say
we
wouldn't do that
but it gets harder to say that
particularly to minority communities
when they come up with when people in
minority communities have a theory or an
argument and we'll talk about some of
them to say we certainly
we wouldn't do that that's not something
that's
that the united states government would
do right
so throughout this period of revelation
one of the things that's so frustrating
is that the people who were involved are
not punished right mk ultra doctors cia
agents that dose people with lsd none of
them go to jail people who are in iran
contra are found guilty but then
pardoned and oftentimes find their way
back into the united states government
right there's revelation without
repercussions and there's a sense that
some people are above the law that yes
the government allowed the small fish to
take the fall but what was really going
on was never revealed and that area that
dark area of we know there are secrets
we know that bad things are done allows
people to come up with conspiracies that
simply expound those into new levels
oftentimes new levels of complication
and horror right
so skull and bones
this was established in 1832 at yale
university it meets in a
windowless
room on yale university campus called
the tomb
it picks people who are going to be
successful about 15 of men and now women
every year have you guys heard of the
skull and bones okay
so
there are this is again there are
societies with secrets but are they
secret societies and how do they tie
into the other things we've talked about
right so this is the skull and bones
class of 47 this is a headline from the
new york times which is yale a great
nursery of spooks one of the things you
might not know about yale is that yale
was directly connected
through its membership into the oss and
later the cia
many of the great leaders of the cia
many of the people that you know number
of people who are assumed to be the
people on the three tramps on the grassy
knoll
were the yalies right cord meyer james
jesus angleton right mick george bundy
all yalies all some of them were skull
and bones some of them weren't who later
went into the oss and then the cia the
cia in 1943 42 members of that class go
on into the oss
right there is a statue in front of
cia headquarters who is nathan hale
nathan hale was the first
spy killed by the british in the in the
american revolution i regret that i have
one one life to give for my country
that ma that statue that is in front of
cia headquarters is a model of another
statue on yale university campus because
nathan hale is yale university class of
73 1773 right now
again you move forward and say but we
get to 2004 you have two bonesmen one
george w bush whose father was a
bonesman whose father was also the head
of the cia also the head of a major oil
company whose father's father his
grandfather prescott bush was also a
bonesman running against another
bonesman in 2004. so now the arguments
are there's a secret society at yale
that's plugged into the american
intelligence agency that's done like the
guys who are sitting and writing
northwoods
you know maybe not but the sense is they
all just came from yale and played
squash together and then said why don't
we have a false flag operation right i
don't know that that's true but you see
the pieces are there right a secret
society of wealthy individuals all
together planning this and this is the
stuff that conspiracy theorists move and
when they were asked about it in the
2004 election both of them refused to
comment
bush saying something to the effect of
it is a secret society and i don't talk
about secret societies
right
so it's a society with secrets
but is it a secret society
right
another one is the bohemian grove has
anyone heard of the bohemian grove
the bohemian grove is a large collection
of trees in northern california redwood
forest
it is the site of a gathering every year
of political cultural
scientific leaders
who come to the forest close to the
press
and live in the trees for two weeks
now this is a can anyone identify anyone
here in this picture
this is 1967 of bohemian grove
nixon on one side reagan on the other
the guy in the middle is harvey hancock
he was the campaign manager for
eisenhower and also a big executive at
pan am
this guy to the left of nixon is glenn
seiborg glenn ceborg has 11 discovered
11 elements was a professor at cal
berkeley was also in the manhattan
project at uc and also was the co-winner
of the nobel prize in 1951.
so he is a leader of and later on moving
for
peace and arms control et cetera but
these are the kinds of people who are
there
now
is it a problem in america that people
have a secret society at yale that and
with yale's connection to
the intelligence community is it a
problem that they gather in places that
are defined as secret the bohemian grove
right
is it a problem that they are there
without press meeting and chatting maybe
maybe not
is it a problem that they put on robes
on one of the first days and have a
ceremony in front of a giant statue of
an owl in which they burn a human effigy
in a ceremony called the cremation of
care
i mean it's weirder right so we have but
so so when someone who is
inclined to conspiracy theories sees
what the american government has
actually done sees the connections that
they can draw then sees that like but
wait they're all wearing robes in front
of a giant owl burning a person a stash
a human in effigy
it gets harder and harder it gets to be
that stuff which is at what point is a
secret society a society with secrets a
secret society at what level does it
reach the point that we should care or
this is still like you're attempting to
put something in a place where it isn't
right
john ronson wrote a book them in which
the experiences that he and alex jones
snuck into the bohemian grove and got
this footage okay um
and it's a real question is this a big
deal at all right because this is the
raw material of conspiracies this is the
kinds of stuff in the raw material for
each conspiracy is going to be a little
different the pieces that they're going
to mix and match to try and make a
conspiracy but we have to recognize that
there is stuff the raw material is out
there for people to make conspiracies
now that doesn't make conspiracies real
it doesn't make it work but we need to
recognize that this is the well of stuff
that people are drawing from who are
coming into your classrooms right all of
this information is on youtube all of
this stuff that when they want to make
these kinds of things these are the raw
materials and if we're going to talk
about these with our students and fellow
americans we need to know some of this
history to recognize what's in bounds
and what's not right
so
elements of a good conspiracy group
international scope a state within a
state helps this is the masons the
catholic church the international banks
the
the maybe even some of these
organizations depending on how you
wanted to find bohemian grove it
stretches beyond national borders it has
famous members if there is a secret
society in which
the highest ranking member is the a
barber from muncie i don't think anyone
cares right but when you have reagan and
nixon in a picture now i'm suddenly i
have you have my attention political
cultural influence again a conspiracy of
people with no power and no influence
has limited effect
money secret rituals and often sexual
abuse this is a
somewhat
disturbing part of a lot of these is
that you take people with robes in front
of the cremation of care ceremony and
you add in a little eyes wide shut
right and you begin to create something
that turns that involves itself into
comet ping pong right the piece of place
that was alleged to have a pedophilia
ring underneath it right in dc
in 2016 right occult knowledge or
connections and some kind of goal right
if if the goal of the secret society is
just to get together and have a party no
one much cares right so
a little bit about ufos and i and i'm
gonna and i know but because this is a
place and one of the things we need to
recognize is that conspiracies don't
simply involve politics
they aren't simply about political power
or connections made at yale or the
international espionage those kinds of
things right or oil or just money or
just those kinds of things there is a
carnival-esque period in which when you
trace many of these conspiracies they're
going to move to the fantastic
the unreal
seemingly
the unbelievable the religious the
miraculous right so ufos have been with
us a long time this is the book of
ezekiel i'm not going to read it all
this is ezekiel's seeing of wheels
within wheels ezekiel chapter 1 that
many people who believe in ufos point to
that we've been visited for a long time
you can go and read and it is
if you read it
in a particular jaundiced eye or maybe
on jaundice die it sounds like a rocket
there's flames and spinning wheels and
it moves from side to side and it hovers
and it roars
so
modern american
ufo culture comes from
kenneth arnold the civilian pilot who
claimed to see objects moving over mount
rainier in 1947
he said they were crescent shaped
but they skipped over like saucers they
were never saucers shaped they were
they were crescent shaped right now
notice again we will talk a little bit
about how part of conspiracy thinking is
there are no coincidences this is 1947
the founding of the now is that a
connection i don't think so but in the
eyes of a conspiracy theorist i can tell
you that dates and times are going to be
very important and they're going to echo
right so in 1947 a public information
officer named walter haught issued a
press release that the air force had
recovered pieces of a flying disk near
roswell new mexico are we familiar with
roswell right roswell has moved roswell
is an almost unknown air base that
no one had heard of prior to this event
and now it is
possibly due mainly to the x-files and
other things it is part of our popular
culture right
they issue a story that they recovered a
flying disc then they issued a
retraction instead of they found a
weather balloon right but it was off and
running the air force investigates ufos
from 1952 to 1970 in project blue book
for those of you of my generation who
watched
the leonard nimoy show
um you know they're all there were a
number of shows investigating project
blue book and this was a very hot thing
in the 1970s to analyze ufo data air
force investigated 12 618 cases most
were explained but a 701 5.6 percent
remain unexplained okay so the uf so
what this reads in the minds of
conspiracy theorists is one ufos are
real enough that uniformed officers of
the air force are going place to place
investigating them and two
they are issuing a report in which
they're finding some unexplained it is
not much of a step to say this is all a
front for clearly men in black going
from place to place and covering up ufos
right
so the next step of alien contact is
abductions right
betty and barney hill is one of the
classic abduction stories it's part of
our popular culture taken there's all
kinds of ufo shows that are going to
involve exactly these kinds of things
right betty and barney hill saw ufo on
september 19th 1961 in new hampshire
they see a craft in figures they
realized that their drive home normally
four hours took more than seven this is
the missing time that is so much a part
of ufo culture
after this encounter betty has a long
series of nightmares and physical
symptoms right after working with a
psychologist a psychiatrist betty and
barney claim they remember exactly what
happened a shift was taken the ship
landed they were taken on board they had
and if i asked you all to write down on
a sheet of paper the types of medical
exams that were done everyone knows now
right right so we could say they were
probed here and there this is what it
looked like we've seen it in popular
culture that this event which seems so
fringy in the 1960s has become literally
all of us could have a conversation
about what a ufo abductions feels like
or sounds like and we've seen
representations of it right
the greys become this popular figure
right and they published a best-selling
book in 1966 called the interrupted
journey so
why
are we talking about ufos because ufos
come back into
conspiracy theories about the government
in very interesting ways from all kinds
of groups
right
that
you know by the 70s people are talking
about roswell as the smoking gun as the
uf
ufo movement proof the air force is
covering up alien contact
there are release documents from a group
called majestic 12 that is alleging that
there was an agreement
at picker air force base
wright-patterson andrews in which there
were
alliances formed between the ufos and
the united states government right
bill cooper is a writer who is a really
leading conspiracy voice who's now dead
but he was a leading voice about this
deep conspiracy in the government that
there's a conspiracy that the government
had made a deal in in
agreement with aliens
in exchange for technology to allow
aliens to kidnap and torture american
people
and that the abduction movement the ufos
the cia all of this is a cover-up of a
giant
ufo
arrangement
right so
it combines the illuminati the
bilderbergers the new world order and
other groups into a kind of super
conspiracy and this is not under unusual
underneath a lot of the conspiracies
that you will discuss in class are
bigger conspiracies that the students
are not going to discuss because they're
arguing about the evidence of one
particular little bit
and it's important to recognize that
these things can grow and spawn and they
involve this kind of carnivalesque stuff
right in 1990 the air force said okay
we'll release all the documents about
this it was project mogul it was a high
altitude weather balloons to discus to
discover whether moscow was doing
nuclear tests
and it crashed but do you think this
helped
right the the issuing of more things was
only was taken in the ufo community as
look how close we're getting they're now
trying to recover the cover-up because
we're about to uncover it we're about to
blow this thing wide open and the more
the government said no here are more
documents the more they looked at and
said these documents are so fake i can't
believe these guys are so scared we are
we have them on the run
so the effort to engage with the
conspiracy at this point only leads to
make the conspiracy stronger as a sense
of well we're totally justified right
so there's other arguments right there
are other arguments that the ufo
conspiracy is a conspiracy a conspiracy
of the air force
so the air force is putting out stories
about ufos so that when people see test
aircraft in the air they don't say oh
that's the
f-37 stealth fighter they say it's a ufo
and so this is a cover-up to get people
to believe in ufos so they aren't paying
attention to what's really going on in
areas like area 51. area 51 is an ariana
government map that no one knew about
prior to conspiracy theorists saying
that that is groom lake where they're
testing the
ufos that they got from the aliens by
allowing them to abduct people and take
their bodily organs
right but have you guys heard of area 51
right so there's the thing that you know
about that's on a government map
literally listed as area 51
because the name is top secret because
we have a national security state that
takes large parts of the united states
territory and says
this is area 51. we can't tell you what
we're doing here we can't tell we're
spending here but it's to keep you safe
trust us
and i understand you need to test
aircrafts and i don't have a problem
with that but as it plays into this
conspiracy theory it is the raw stuff
to allow this stuff to go on right the
other one is that the ufos are a
cover-up
because what they're really doing is
they're they are taking people and
probing them and
torturing them and doing medical
experiments on them or their cattle
cattle mutilation comes in here now
but the cover-up is rather than it being
black helicopters of the united states
government kidnapping people drugging
them and torturing them to do medical
experiments on them instead it is ufos
so whoever's out in the cattle ranch
gets mad at ufos and not at the united
states government so yes it's a
conspiracy but it's a conspiracy of a
conspiracy hiding a bigger conspiracy
these are the mazes
these are the wheels these are the mag
the mazes we go down right
so again these might seem
silly but they show how conspiracy
theories expand and darken as they move
forward right from a government covering
up technology or covering up something
they've seen in the sky to the wholesale
torture of americans
right oftentimes these things will move
in a religious way
that this plot of the ufos that the ufos
are not aliens from andromeda but that
they are in fact luciferian beings right
that religion is going to come involved
in some of these conspiracies and it's
going to be very common depending on
which conspiracies we're looking at
right
so
journalist michael kelly
argued in 1995 for what he called fusion
paranoia
it was a union of the radical left and
right which are often seen as very
distinct groups
but a union of them
in the shared fear of one thing above
all the boundless kabbalistic evil of
the government and its allies that as
you go to the left and the right you
find that the villains become the same
and it's quite often the us government
so that what we think of there there had
been leftist movements like the
weathermen there were
leftist movements the red army faction
in europe but there are also the growth
of right-wing movements patriot
movements militias the order aryan
nations posse comatatus both of these
groups
could get together and agree on nothing
about the political outcomes they want
but they both agree that the target that
they've chosen is the united states
government that is oppressing both the
rights of african americans whether you
want to look at um you know philadelphia
and the the battle in downtown
philadelphia or you want to look at
right-wing movements in idaho they are
all identifying the exact same enemy
that is the national security state and
all of the conspiracies of the federal
government right
in 1991 george h.w bush
bonesman
yalesman former head of the cia comes
forward and gives a speech about the new
world order
many people who heard that said well
that makes sense
the soviet union has just fallen
we have had a 50-plus year
cold war in which we split the war
between the world between communist and
capitalists now one of those is gone it
is time to remake the world and the new
phrase a new world order seems utterly
unremarkable i can guarantee you for
other people listening with different
ears the
bonesman h.w bush former director of the
cia declaring a new world order is a
message to his skull and bones alumni in
the secret brotherhood right
for these people ruby ridge which was
randy weaver uh in a in idaho getting
delivered a warrant the fbi and other uh
agencies were attempting to use him as a
as a witness or as a
source against the aryan nations he
didn't want to they were going to arrest
him on gun charges
and it turned into an armed standoff in
which his wife and and other members of
his family are killed waco in 1993
the standoff in waco texas for 51 days
around the branch davidian compound
again combining
the federal government religious
believers the branch davidians who have
an end of the world message
about the coming apocalypse like many
american religions including the one i
was brought up into southern baptist had
this belief in the federal government
then rolls in acting the role of the
government that they would see them play
in the book of revelation that turns
into a 51 day standoff and ends in mass
death and an invasion by
an incursion into the fbi and atf saying
this has gone on long enough that turns
into a fireball that ends up killing
lots of people right
all of these things in the context of
the national security state of ufos of
the american government is hiding it of
both left and right seeing the american
government as the fault as the problem
the revelations of the 1970s and the
1980s and now the declaration of a new
world order a standoff in ruby ridge are
they coming for our guns a standoff
against religious people in the branch
davidians who are
a compound again that you have
accusations of sex and religious
radicalism and now surrounded by the
united states government that ends in a
fireball the sense that this is a
natural first step
to suppress and exterminate the american
people and there might be a lot of
different
versions of exactly what the conspiracy
are which of this
melange of lego pieces of conspiracy
i've laid out for you how they're
putting them together but they all come
to some similar conclusions of the fault
of the united states government trust no
one they
lie to us
and it ends
in oklahoma city well it doesn't end
it's a mid
timothy mcveigh is at waco
there's footage of him selling stickers
anti-governmental stickers on the back
of his car watching waco and when he he
blows this up and ed knows this as well
as anybody right he makes a statement
that this he is a war that the united
states government has declared war in
1991 in ruby ridge 1993 at waco and this
is the next act that he sees this as
pushing back against a federal
government out of control that is part
of a long detailed oftentimes
anti-semitic aryan nations conspiracy
theory about what has happened to the
united states government pick your
pieces from the lego box
of
masons
jewish bankers and put them together but
this event is coming out of that
conspiracy
theories right and coming out of the
actions of the united states government
that have allowed these conspiracy
theories in many ways to and not to
fault them right understanding
maintaining a secret state a national
security state and intelligence
organizations is allowing these a lot of
these claims to be made and also the
actions of the things that were done in
mk ultra and northwoods and these other
things that are coming out
makes it harder and harder to make the
case we'd love to make which is we would
never
do that right
so this is gore vidal he is on the left
he's a longtime leftist critic
of american empires he said
and he wrote
about the shredding of the bill of
lights he declared vicky and sam weaver
shot at ruby ridge as victims of quote
cold-blooded federal murder and the waco
fire as quote fbi slaughter of the
innocents he wrote that quote most of
today's actual terrorists can be found
within our own governments federal state
and municipal i'm not sure if you would
say that 9 11. it seems like a strange
thing to say
but it does tell you where gore vidal is
as far politically as timothy mcveigh
could be
right
he's friend of the kennedys like deep
within the democratic structure but is
also a critical united states and they
become pen pals
when timothy mcveigh is imprisoned
and in their letters they correspond on
how much they have in common
and their beliefs
right
and this is tying into 911 being an
inside job right this is it is
unsurprising given what i have laid out
all of the pieces in the lego box that
are there for our students or fellow
americans when they go searching on
youtube or they watch a show or hear a
talk these are the things they're
putting together and to come to the
conclusion that this is an inside job
this is four years after the revolution
that they had actually discussed a false
flag operation in project northwoods
that they never did
but the claim that bush knew ekko's
claims that fdr was behind the pearl
harbor attack that he so wanted to get
involved in war in europe that he
allowed either allowed pearl harbor to
have or actually took a stronger hand in
it and uh
even harder to prove conspiracy right
so so many of these um claims about 911
and noah we'll get into them in much
more detail that there are planted
explosives that there was no plane that
hit the pentagon moving to levels of
luciferianism that these were
these were actually missiles and not
planes with holographic planes around
them depending on how far you want to
stretch the kind of unreality and the
the bounds of reality that they're going
to use but these are important issues
and part of
a debate right the debate about 911 and
noah can talk about it part of it is
evidence and depending on who you're
talking to they might just be having an
evidential debate
what would it take how does a building
collapse will steal mill these kinds of
things but there are some people for
whom that debate about the evidentiary
basis of 9 11 or any one of these is a
cover for a deeper
anxiety the anxiety of they lie to us
trust no one
and that the conversation about 911 is
only the tip of an iceberg of all of
this other stuff that's behind it of how
we think about democracy how we think
about how the american government works
and our relationship to it
this is all for the first part and we'll
move to the second part after the break
but we can have some questions if you'd
like
uh do you want to do
i think they need you to have a mic
don't panic
you'll hold it no panic okay um so uh
do you
oh this is weird okay do you see a
difference
um between the conspiracy theories that
from what i can tell seem to be very
much like white men distrusting other
white men and the well-founded distrust
that many communities of color have for
a government that has you know
consistently oppressed and killed them
over and over again is there a i think
you're absolutely right and i would
advise you to stay tuned for the next
hour oh yeah yeah no i mean we're going
to talk about it right there are i mean
that the claim that we're going to talk
about how conspiracies break down
racially and the types of conspiracies
there are but absolutely given the long
history of what
american government and americans
empower in white society i mean
right slavery is that a white american
male phenomena i guess i'm wondering um
i think that's a great question
no no so i think well what i would like
to say is i would like to address that
question in the next hour okay but but
let me say that had i not thought of
that question it would be a truly
devastating great question but yes so
yeah uh yes
i'm sorry
uh to what extent is this totally an
american phenom like can you speak to if
this exists internationally at all
i
can try to i think it is there are
i don't think it is an american
phenomenon
i think if you look at other governments
particularly the soviet union and
communists were rife with conspiracies
when you have a i think any place you
have a government that is not responsive
or secret parts of the government
in which the how the
function of political governments and
political economy isn't clear i think
you have conspiracies i think even in
a little league in a fantasy football
league you have conspiracies where
someone's like well i can't believe they
want to switch to ppr there's a
conspiracy right so i think it's
partially naturally in us i also think
that
one of the things that make it
and again i'm talking without evidence
so i'm just kind of
so recognized that all of this could be
revised by better scholarship
um i think one of the things that makes
us particularly rife
post 1947 is the massive power of the
united states like we talked about a
great conspiracy matters you have
important people and a lot of money
america has
a lot of money and huge power and the
ability to power project in ways that if
you were
saying
sweden or lithuania or belize if belize
has a lot of horrible ideas
i'm not sure that they're having a whole
lot of effect but america has a
worldwide empire and again i'm not to
call it an empire but we are in
what 100 countries we have military
bases around the world we have nearly
unlimited capital economic system flows
right through the city of new york we
have the most powerful biggest most
expensive military in the world we have
satellites we went to the moon there is
if there is a country with the possible
exception of the soviet union that has
the power to do bad things if it is
inclined to do bad things
it's the united states so the fact that
america has confessed to doing some bad
things and it has the means and the
opportunity right again if belize says
we have a plot for worldwide domination
i'm not sure where that goes other than
wow some of the people in belize are
really messed up but if belize had a
worldwide power projection possibility
then those conspiracies can get a lot
more
i mean there are
at weather mountain or the greenbrier or
cheyenne there are giant underground
complexes that are dug that are bomb
proof we have an entire infrastructure
that was designed to
accept the fact that we were probably
going to be in a nuclear war we have
laws drawn up that allow certain parts
of the government to be completely
non-democratic which in the eyes of some
people are like well see we already have
the plan all we have to do is announce a
national emergency and we can dissolve
this or do this or do this plans that
were made up in the middle of the cold
war so america is in a position because
of its power and its um
extent in its reach that those
conspiracies can be truly scary in the
way that conspiracy about other places
might not be but i do think that
i think if
having been a teenager anytime you get
three people together two of them are
plotting against the third one that
might be unfair but i think so
conspiracy is not that rare yeah
recent years it feels like there's more
and more of a conversation about how
people are only reading news that
supports what they already think people
are looking for information that's
already supporting what their mindset is
so how because like i i'm not a believer
in conspiracy theories like at all but
i'm looking at this and i'm like sure
like if you're trying if you're trying
to prove there's a conspiracy you can
always find that one detail you're like
well this part hasn't been solved right
whereas a lot of people would be like
yeah because it's nothing like other
people are looking for that and they're
always going to gravitate towards that
is that a part of it but then also to
what extent is it like people not taking
responsibility for like
other like actions that are happening
like oh like we're not gonna say that
this is what's really happening so we're
gonna like and we don't wanna admit to
what might be the problem and we're just
gonna go with the conspiracy because
that's easier than like thinking what
actually
might be a problem and addressing it oh
i think that's exactly right and i think
again we're going to talk about this in
the second half which is that what
attracts what is the attractive part of
conspiracy theories like what is the
right i mean a conspiracy theory isn't
simply just
it's very seldom
the best answer for the given evidence
right so there's other things going on
what is emotionally attractive about
conspiracies what is uh politically
attracted about conspiracies and you're
right i mean part of it is
the world's super complicated
and we want to have answers for it and
there are times in which because of that
complex nature conspiracy theories seem
easier and more attractive because they
explain more things but we're going to
talk a whole lot more about that but i
do also think that the
division of news in which you consume
only that news which seems to most agree
with what you believe
leads to a lack of contrary um
opinions and examples so yeah so i think
that's absolutely true yeah please
uh yes you've been talking about um
conspiracy theories that people have
about government yeah but in this
administration
it's like
they are the ones promoting some
conspiracy theories
like the birther movement um
trump also mentioned uh ted cruz his dad
being um oh yeah involved in the jfk
assassination
uh michael flynn and the pizza hillary
clinton
yeah and so many others and that is
extremely scary that some of the
followers because trump has a lot of
supporters might actually believe those
conspiracy theories because they're
coming from from them from him no i
think you're right if you look at comet
ping pong right a guy shows up at a
rifle i was gonna we could talk about it
if you wanted to in some detail about
the imagery and the way symbolism is
used there but i think what
so
i mean there's no way around i mean the
one of the things in that
achieved political takeoff for donald
trump was his opposition to obama and
pushing birtherism right i mean he is
attached to that early on as a kind of
and i don't think it's the only reason
he won but it certainly was a reason i
would actually say that part of this is
we started i think that many times and
we've talked about this in various ways
we see conspiracies as weird separate
apart from the way
people think about stuff and i think
trump to his credit
said
there's a lot of people who think like
me or
there's a lot of people who think like
this
and i can motivate them and mobilize
them to become
active political participants in a way
that other politicians would think well
i won't ever talk about that because
it's horrible or untrue or no one's
going to respond to that or people will
think i'm a nut i think
trump didn't have that opinion right
i'll sliver i have a very quick question
than a longer one quick one is um
building off of rick's question from
earlier are you going to talk about the
role of women in conspiracy movements a
little bit um there is
surprisingly if you look at the the most
of the scholarship of it women
there's some scholarship on conspiracy
belief among women but much less on
conspiracy perpetuation among women and
most of the
not perhaps not surprising it's very
masculinist and in fact anti-feminist
and so
um in fact
depending on which conspiracy you're
looking at things like the feminist
movement movement of the 1960s is seen
as one of the things that they are
acting against particularly in aryan
nations and possible tattoos and a lot
of these right-wing movements are very
much about traditional female values and
so there isn't really a space for them
to
be the kind of engineers of
video there's not a lot of work on their
work on there's a lot of work on women
in radical movements or movement in
extreme movements but much less on women
as leaders of those movements
because i agree i think i almost never
think of women right i always think of
men being like oh well this is all a
conspiracy yeah yeah sure you're right
right it's just not so but i will say
that that's not entirely true because in
some depending on what community you're
looking at in some groups
to the degree that religion is an
important factor for example randy
weaver's wife
had visions of an apocalypse had visions
of going to a mountain and that she was
really the religious she was in some
ways the leader of the family all the
way around was that then they moved to
idaho because they thought the
apocalypse was coming so
where religion comes into this there
very very often is a powerful woman
figure on that though there's also a
very much a masculinist depending on
which group we're talking about
masculinist warrior culture
that puts women into the background on
that
yeah well i mean yeah there is i mean
there certainly is
that we don't i mean phyllis schaffler
probably is a conspiracy theorist but i
think we don't tend to think of her as
that but there are women in eagle forum
and these kinds of places um
that are pushing some of these things so
i think it's right but there's you're
right but they certainly is i can say
that in the literature they play a
perhaps very much undeserved small role
that i think they deserve a lot more
attention
you have a second question
um yeah so i was thinking about
okay
so when you were talking about like how
like
the people like the power of the united
states like engenders conspiracy
theories i was thinking about like north
korea and how the entire population is
like brainwashed to believe that like
they're the most absolutely powerful
nation in the world and they're perfect
and like everyone else is like this
horrible person and this like screwed up
place um
but you don't really have conspiracy
theories there i i yeah i mean it's hard
to know right we don't know but it's a
great question there is also i think
what you have there is a cult of
personality but you also have the idea
that kim shot
played a round of golf and had 18
hole-in-ones right or when he was born
well when he was born like there was a
double eclipse and five rainbows like
there's so there is that kind of that
kind of myth building that i don't know
that i quite do
like i don't know that it's quite a
conspiracy but it is interesting to
think about what in those closed
communities that are
dominated by a cult of personality the
kinds of things you have so is
brainwashing the solution to no
conspiracy yeah yeah
do you have a question
um you you showed that they've been
around forever but i was just wondering
have they kind of changed and morphed
and grown since the advent of the
internet and people to be able to
communicate instantaneously and around
the world but it's a really interesting
question right um
that
there are the kind of
techno
prophets who say that once we'll all be
able to talk to each other
we're going to move to this new level of
intelligent discourse and then
there's the internet
which is not that um yeah so i think the
internet has been key to this i mean
it's
you know again if we looked at say comet
ping pong which starts on a reddit board
in
november 4th
and within a week it's become
on
tv on fox news talking about this event
this thing in which there's this l you
know allegation that there's a
pedophilia ring underneath this
pizza place in dc frequented by
um
powerful politicians particularly
democrats linked to to john podesta's
emails being leaked in which they talk
about pizza
because
my sense is if you have a bunch of
political volunteers you buy them a lot
of pizza but people on the internet
going through he's saying pizza so much
you know that pizza is code for
pedophilic sex with children
and that's what they're talking about so
i mean so the internet allows that
community that that idea which is what
it allows is
one person or a group of people have an
idea and it might be a joke like it
might be just for the lulls it might be
just a like they're playing a joke on
somebody but they started into the
internet which now can spread so rapidly
that everyone who has an inclination
about that or an interest in that can
now be part of that community and it
spreads to the point that again
less than a month later
on november 3rd my guess is outside of a
six block area at comet pink around the
pizza place no one's ever heard of this
place right but it turns into the idea
that all these businesses are linked and
there's this pedophilic symbolism that's
showing that and there's underground
tunnels and all of this is put together
and there's children in cages
underground being kept so that powerful
politicians can have and the elite can
have sex with children
and it gets to a guy in north carolina
who i guarantee you a month earlier has
never heard of comet ping pong
and he gets an ar-15 type rifle
and he drives to do what he called
self-investigation and walks into the
restaurant and shoots into the floor and
gets arrested i mean that that kind of
speed in which something can go from
literally not existing not a just
popularizing a conspiracy theory but
literally not existing and being created
on the internet by the activity of
people who are putting in some of them
are cl there's a picture of
obama at comet ping pong in which he's
addict first of all isn't actually maybe
he's actually holding a ping-pong paddle
but it's in like the north part of the
white house like the red carpet with a
ping pong table in the middle but it
says obama at comet ping pong
i mean i don't know who believes that
some it might be someone makes it as a
joke and passed it to a friend who then
puts it on this you know reddit page and
then it's in
the kind of you know it's a new kind of
conspiracy disease vector in the kind of
mind of the body politic so i yeah i
think we'll talk about it some more but
i think i mean i the internet certainly
has allowed communities that otherwise
communicated much more slowly to
communicate much more rapidly and evolve
much faster in a way that's kind of
surprising and shocking i mean i i
unfortunately spend more time engaging
with people on the internet
that i
definitely don't want to meet in real
life um but but it's it's and it's
shocking how fast these things can
metastasize so yeah one more question
um so
you know going to what you just said and
also you know something that struck me
as you were talking about the
uh history of the like the illuminati
and the breakup of the illuminati and
how there becomes this um
evidence kind of
how they get how they gather evidence
and create argument toward the argument
that they want to make
um which made me think of the idea that
you know in a conspiracy situation that
there is no trusted source then because
like you said your source is
contaminated by people who
want you to see or you know what they
want you to see
um which kind which really led me to
kind of this the modern era of kind of
you of your truth
you have your facts i have my truth i
have my facts and kind of made me wonder
if a lot of this comes down to like like
just the idea that beliefs don't need
proof
because you have what you believe and i
have whatever right i mean so where
we're in i mean imagine if we go back
right to stefan diggs right who is an
unusual person to put in let's have an
evidentiary argument about
how we think of knowledge and let's turn
to stefan diggs wide receiver of the
vikings but the idea is
you can
go ahead and prove it to me right now
but don't give me a picture that you got
from somewhere because they lie to us
right what we're in is this weird
evidentiary space in which technology
has made it
even pre-photoshop the idea that the
evidence you're giving me is fake
because i have decided that nasa is a
front to fake the moon landing so the
pictures you're giving me as evidence
can't work as evidence because i've
already decided that because they are
part of the conspiracy none of that
evidence can be trusted so there is no
evidence and i think we're at a point
now this is i was an english major as
well undergrad and we talked about
post-modernism and moving past truth and
the idea was that this was going to be
really great because we were unc we were
overthrowing master narratives of
of kind of you know inherent ideas of
gender or power or capitalism or these
kinds of things and we would be free out
of these master narratives and we'd be
in a post where the kind of the powerful
wouldn't have be able to control the
narratives well we're here
so this is what it looks like right in
an area where you say how do we engage
and talk about these issues when we
won't share a world view of what counts
as evidence
and when we're in an area and again this
is where
it moves towards religion right you
would never say to someone and i grew up
and i say i believe the lord jesus died
for my sins you're like well give me
that evidence right there are some
claims that are safe in our culture away
from evidentiary claims we're not going
to have that argument right or maybe we
will but it's going to be uncomfortable
but that sense of belief has moved in
many cases beyond what we would think of
as traditionally religious questions but
i would also argue from some of this
many of arguments about conspiracies are
religious questions they function like
religious questions not like political
questions and that can put us in a
really gray area as we try to debate
them that make sense yeah so we'll talk
about it more so
thank you
the second part of this college lecture
series in a moment with a look at
conspiracies and how they've changed in
modern american society
later 20th century ufo conspiracies when
they started and why they're still
popular
you're watching american history tv
programs normally only on weekends here
on c-span 3 saturday mornings at 80
eastern through monday morning at 8 but
congress is on break this month and
we're taking the opportunity to show you
american history tv during the week
if you miss any of